[Music]
Thanks for seeing me last-minute things
are seeing me so last-minute no problem
at all Kelsey so what's going on down
there today
sure thing Kate what's going on oh I
can't stop eating cannot stop feeling
like I have to pee so what do you think
brought this on my mom probably um well
I went out with Kelsey last night and I
didn't want to you know my bestie Kate
she's been kind of anti-social lately
Jerry watching Friday night like I
wanted to take her somewhere fun so it
forced me to go with her to this shitty
warehouse pop-up farm which is like sort
of a total fire hazard and everyone
there was like super hot on Molly
anyways this group of guys
HECO 5dj came up and started talking to
us and they're super funny he was being
pretty rude to them he said I look like
I love horses and I started hitting it
off with this guy and we had this crazy
connection she took Molly with him kate
starts looking at me all judgmental but
some guy in clogs hit me in the auto the
glow stick so I thought I'd give her
some space
so I left and my phone was dead so I had
to walk home with one eye and when I
finally inish I was so tired so I just
fell into a stupor and started rage
eating everything in my fridge and
forgot to pee do you think Kelsey is
perhaps a source of stress in your life
no it just sounds like she's just not as
fun as she used to be oh I don't know it
sounds like your friend Kate's holding
you back and having fun no no it's not
like that it's just to be taken
seriously you may want to continue it
so it's UTI I'll meet you up front
great um my therapist said something
like kind of weird yes oh actually that
reminds me I've been wanting to tell you
something okay
[Music]
IFS red red flame
[Music]
see I went on a run yeah I didn't expect
it are you on anything else
does your mom Oh